hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm Dan
cider
we're gonna be reviewing the trailer
today for a grand theft auto 5 the
heists trailer mmmmmm as I was talking
to Dan before this video he was telling
me about how it's taken quite a while to
put this game together
well the online gameplay yeah I mean
heist was something that was kind of
like once it was introduced in like the
main story was like this is gonna be
awesome and multi player and it just it
kind of I don't know took quite a bit
longer than I think a lot of people are
expecting for it to actually hit grand
theft auto online just is that's that's
that's a magical experience really is my
first let's play was on frickin GTA
online I I so know that because I don't
you don't I watch your channel I
moderately what you do I know you've
been complaining but you weren't ready
lead the crew to take a school
all right curse things a plane then we
got a bus we got the inmate transfer
schedule that's a two-person job sure
they're not following you
this will require a little bit of
finesse simple should be the easiest
money you'll ever make
that's a great tease if you know what
Grand Theft Auto is already and knowing
that it's mayn't the sent around Heights
is [ __ ] cool because it makes Grand
Theft Auto much more specific [ __ ] who
the hell doesn't want to be part of the
heist yeah yeah yeah nice is not so fun
for some reason so remember like before
the video I was telling you that it took
quite a while to come out with it first
line out of the whole damn trailer was I
know you've been complaining but you
weren't ready yeah clearly we were not
ready a big scrap that thought oh cool
every evening since Grand Theft Auto 3
when the graphics were nowhere near as
good as they are now it's always felt
kind of like a movie it's like a movie
but even more than that okay it's a
whole [ __ ] world you're allowed to be
in it's not like hatred where you're
just a mass murderer are we gonna do it
let's not do this so good I don't want
to do that we're gonna get enough hatred
for talking about hatred so yeah I don't
want to go into it as far as this goes
um I I in general like heist movies from
heat to Ocean's eleven you know I love
all those kinds of films to see this in
the grand theft auto world and have it
be an online game you know that's I'm
kind of speechless it's there's so much
possibilities and so much potential for
something so awesome in a way kind of
the heart of what makes GTA like gray is
because that means a crime game you're
committing crimes which is what's get
past that but the idea that you're now
doing bank heists instead of just like
running to drugstore stick them up get
your leg at fifty dollars doopa doopa
doopa do this is like major heist like
going in and like jacking jewelry from
like yeah everything and robbing banks
it's like there's coordination exactly
what because grand theft auto is usually
like a bunch of different missions but
they're they're fairly simple to follow
and this one dudes yeah and this one
there they have a guy who's like okay we
got a map out everything you know like
we gotta take this plane we gotta take
this car we gotta go into this vault at
this time and like if you're working
with a team online that is like real
team work for being a criminal only you
know it makes it a little more
complicated but if you have a
multiplayer
going on here that makes it a lot more
exciting because now you really have to
cooperate it's kind of what online was
missing when I first started playing on
the online I actually really want to go
back and play head now after watching
this it was missing this sort of you
know cooperative thing I mean there was
there was like this wave survival thing
that you could do which was pretty
straightforward it was like survive 10
rounds and it's actually pretty easy to
do you know there was missing something
bigger and I feel like this is just like
yes yeah that's a it's a it's like this
this is what we wanted I like the guy
who's kind of in charge of you know
setting all this up they do it Larry
no I don't walk welding guy with glasses
yes I know it starts with an L I love
his personality it seems very much like
he's from a movie and at the same time
it's like he's not the typical dude you
would expect to be in charge of this
because he doesn't look like he could
pull off something like this oh yeah
he's he's awesome no he's pretty sweet
kind reminds me of you if you got a lot
older and a lot a lot fatter and a lot
bolder yeah mm-hmm so if you just change
your whole appearance you would look
like him no I think we just wait 20
years okay you get a fly around in that
jet at one point someone's got a rocket
launcher at one point the armored takes
the armored things yeah it just looks
like the ultimate you know it's kind of
like a more violent version of what the
Fast and the Furious movies have become
mmm because those be sort of turned in
like heist films in a way it's kind of
like that over-the-top really amped up
but it's Grand Theft Auto so it's gonna
be like way more violent and vulgar and
graphic nudity or whatever I don't know
but it's it's just gonna be like the
r-rated version of what we cannot get in
cinema I honestly hope that there's one
heist that you can do does just like
cook so sarcastic going in and like
stealing toys from a Toys R Us
Christmastime
there should be a Christmastime heist
what I like about what this trailer
shows us is that it goes like all over
the place the times like you're just in
the city at times you're kind of looking
like you're in the middle of nowhere you
know yeah times rattle of the ocean you
know I like a game that just takes you
all across like the globe pretty much
that's what I mean it's like it's more
than just like a bank robbery hi scheme
it's like real [ __ ] robberies that
a lot of strategy you know I like
strategy games alive because they make
you feel smart by the time you're done
sewing a puzzle it makes you feel real
good right makes you feel good in here
and down there too so yeah it helps out
on all areas anyway guys thanks for
selling me a trailer was out if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects and dan has a gaming
channel where he does game stuff so
check that out too game stuff yeah
that's why it's a gaming channel
shoutouts will continue soon so go to
facebook.com slash the real reject
shoutouts
we need ammo say something interesting
say something cool yeah and earn
yourself a shout out like like Dan's
poop is yellow actually the thing is
like a really big health concern for me
I was wondering if you could take a look
I have I pointed and laughed and I took
a photo and showed it to all my friends
damnit that was private medical things
my poop is fine I don't know why you
want me to take my piss my pie was mine
but my poop is fine stay out my poop is
fine poop is yellow